et aux etats unis aussi le variant micro
ne provoque une flambée des
contaminations des chiffres record
pourrait être atteint selon les
autorités on en parle justement avec
notre correspondant à washington tom
abonnés
thomas bonsoir alors tout simplement
quelle est la situation en ce moment aux
états unis
est bien ici aussi on assiste à une
hausse très importante du nombre de
contaminations plus de 200 mille
nouveaux cas par jour en moyenne sur la
semaine qui vient de s'écouler le nombre
moyen de cas positifs est actuellement
plus élevés que lors du pic du mois de
janvier évidemment c'est une hausse qui
est provoqué par l'émergence du variant
omicron qui est présent sur l'ensemble
du territoire américain notamment dans
des états tels que le new jersey le
massachussets ont encore l'état de new
york anthony fochi le monsieur santé de
la maison blanche prévient que cette
hausse devrait se poursuivre pendant au
moins plusieurs jours pour autant pour
le moment la hausse des admissions à
l'hôpital ne suis pas réellement la
courbe des nouvelles contaminations mais
les autorités sanitaires américaines se
montrent prudentes sur les affirmations
selon lesquelles le variant omicron
serait moins sévère que le variant delta
surtout elle invite les américains à se
faire vacciner parce que à ce jour 62 %
de la population américaine est
entièrement vacciner alors en termes de
réponse politique on se rappelle que joe
biden a pris la parole la semaine
dernière en se montrant plutôt rassurant
à la proche de la période des fêtes
aujourd'hui il s'est entretenu avec des
gouverneurs d'abord pour leur assurer
que le gouvernement fédéral était prêt à
les aider en cas de besoin et aussi pour
insister sur l'importance de conserver
les écoles ouvertes dans la mesure du
possible en réalité le gros chantier
pour la maison blanche c'est d'augmenter
la capacité de test parce qu'il est
assez difficile de se faire tester
rapidement et gratuitement aux états
unis les autotests sont en rupture de
stock dans un certain nombre de
commerces et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la maison blanche a annoncé la
mise à disposition prochainement de
milliers d'autos test pour les
américains puis enfin en ce qui concerne
les restrictions vous le savez ici elles
sont très localisés
viens aux états voire aux villes de
prendre des mesures c'est par exemple
new york qui est très sévère dans sa
lutte contre la pandémie de commis 19 à
partir de ce lundi le pass vaccinale a
été étendu pour toutes les personnes de
plus de 12 ans ces personnes doivent
désormais montrer une preuve qu'elles
ont reçu au moins deux doses de vaccin
pour pouvoir accéder à certains
établissements merci beaucoup tôt - en
direct de washington